for the last nine months abhishek TV ad
has been sleeping on a couch at his
brother's place in berlin
he's a computer programmer earning more
than fifty thousand euros a year but
he's unable to find an apartment he can
afford to rent eventually when you work
hard you get things done yeah you I
tried to learn German which is pretty
hard but to integrate I learned German
as well a little bit and I found my job
and everything's great but when it comes
to apartment no matter it just have to
be lucky if you just work hard you go to
appointments every day maybe one day
you're so lucky that you find somebody
but it's somebody who's willing to give
you the place but for now it hasn't
worked for me and it's really really
frustrating that you cannot do anything
about it it's out of your hand
Berlin is booming partly thanks to IT
specialists like TV ad but the influx of
new arrivals in recent years German and
non-german alike has caused a housing
shortage in the German capital like many
companies in Berlin do Avedis employer
is headquartered in an old factory
building his boss fears that experiences
like to Avedis are putting talented
foreigners off relocating to berlin or
even to germany plus there's the extra
bother involved in red tape the stencil
bye-bye they have to help with the
bureaucracy bust the visa processing and
finding housing when we have to wait
four months while they process a visa
for a colleague who's come from Pakistan
that really hampers us and diesel our
movement them to Silas D relations Evo
this is one of the spaces that we've
rented and reserved we have a lot of IT
positions vacant right now we saw how
tightly packed the other floor was and
we're desperate to fill those positions
when doing interviews but we have to
look outside Germany because there's so
much competition in Berlin no Marcus
fiesel camp
black lane runs an online chauffer
service customers can book a limousine
and driver in more than 250 cities
worldwide three out of every four of the
employees there hail from abroad from
the likes of Portugal and South Korea if
Germany wants to attract the best and
brightest say startup bosses it needs to
amend its immigration rules because
let's give our vote on positive
legislation should allow graduates from
certain faculties and top universities
to come to Germany and apply to jobs
directly they shouldn't have to take
this complicated route through all this
bureaucracy employers should be able to
make the decision themselves both from
Germany is an attractive location for
startups and should take advantage of
this opportunity in the salon proposal
for Knutson yen's Volkov can't wait for
a new immigration legislation he set up
an eight-person department especially to
recruit foreign employees usually a
figure on earth order is we're going to
this is what we call our talent
management department their job is to
quickly identify suitable candidates who
would be a good match for our vacant
positions and we don't unless they then
get in touch and tried to persuade the
candidates to come to Berlin he's
Italian we guide the talented people
through the entire process until they're
properly settled down the Consul come
career-wise I reject we've ad has
settled in his programming skills are
being put to good use
integrating the black Lane chauffeur
service with travel websites it's a job
he'd be happy to keep doing for years to
come Europe in general is pretty nice it
the work/life balance
in Germany is so wonderful and just
you're on a weekend you can travel to a
different country experience new culture
food and everything and economically
also Germany is one of the best
countries Berlin is courting the world's
best young minds but it also has to
deliver attractive conditions if it can
do that it could lose ground to Europe's
other startup hubs
you